I'm pretty dumb.
That's a really lumpy looking...
Oh my god, I forgot about this.
I forgot about painting my booty.
Yeah.
I think we're all of the best.
Damn!
Oh my god, the painting part?
There's so many things.
You can change your brush size.
Oh my god.
I'm going to paint that.
Oh, Doki, I'm watching.
Wait, you have the same idea as me.
No, no, no, no.
I didn't see the idea from you.
I stole this idea from a dragon Does it look like I'm
wearing a skirt or does it look like I pooped myself?
Um Are you guys already guys starting games?
Oh my god We have 53 seconds Okay I might have made it too
short So we've already started I'm gonna give you an extra
20 seconds of grace Cause Nimmy didn't realize we were
playing yet So I'm just gonna stand here and wait One hour
later Three two i'm coming oh my god she just walked past me
this house is really freaking big i'm not gonna lie yeah i'm
in the library right now don't you just inventing there's a
library oh that's why the whistle is a tv signing swan
that's actually wait i want to see you're getting hot you're
getting hot in here you're getting cold vegetable oh my god
you're getting hot you're getting hot you're getting cold
you're getting cold oh no the team's out of the house I was
trying to get her back.
Sabotage her back, Nini.
I was making up shit.
Making up incredibly accurate shit.
I cannot see you.
Where could she be?
Where could her time be?
It's pretty creative.
Oh, okay.
That's a little longer than I expected there.
Oh my god.
Remember the plan, girls.
You whistle at me because I'm sexy.
an idea i know what i'm gonna be oh this might be too
ambitious never mind i'm no longer confident in my idea all
right ladies oh my god you're spotting i wonder if it's
gonna be very obvious when i see somebody mine's pretty dumb
i don't think i'm gonna live oh no oh my god somebody's
close
now but it's obvious when you see somebody coming from here
somewhere you know how you're close to somebody when
everybody shuts up no i was just adjusting my volume i was
being quiet because i was scared oh you're getting warmer
yeah you're getting colder oh oh no oh just run just run oh
no nine seconds you have eight seven only a few seconds oh
Yeah!
Good job!
Where were you?
Oh, that's really good!
See, I told you that one was gonna clutch it for us.
This one I kind of fucked around with?
Fucked around with.
Where are you, yes?
That color picker doesn't work!
Ah!
Oh no!
Be final words, whoever this person is in the corner of the
vending machine.
Try and run.
I...
Final words is, uh, B7.
If you see my hiding spot, it's so bad.
You're hot, then you're cold, you're yes, then you're no,
you're in, then you're out.
30 more seconds.
Oh my god, come on, come on, come on.
You'll never find me.
Where's the whistle?
Give me one more whistle.
Come on, give me one more.
Oh.
I don't need one more whistle.
I don't need it.
How did you know?
Was it because of the close to me score?
No, I literally was just like, I'm going to crouch down.
I thought it was a gamer, honestly.
when it's Doki.
Of course Doki would look up, guys.
Yeah, that's right.
We should make men be the seeker.
What does that mean?
You're going to try and find us.
How do I find you guys?
Oh, you got to wait.
You got to wait.
We're painting.
We're painting right now.
I don't think my hiding spot is that good, but...
It won't be.
I'll find you.
Yeah!
So this is my first time playing this game.
How do you find?
You shoot who you think is a person.
First time for us, dude.
That's all.
Wait, I actually couldn't tell.
I think I just got really lucky.
I actually saw you stop me.
I didn't actually see anybody in the air.
Oh, I see somebody.
Oh, my God.
You're enjoying us.
Oh, shoot.
I can't get on the top of this whole house.
I'm flying.
I see you.
Oh, my God.
That's so beautiful.
He was practicing.
The pig.
wait i have an idea i have no idea where to hide guys i
think i chose the wrong spot a few moments later okay okay i
think i fixed it that's actually pretty good now dokey yeah
yeah yeah there's some issues from certain angles she won't
look at the angle right don't don't
big dodges i was like that's a really lumpy looking guy wait
i have an idea i'm gonna get context clues by what you're
saying right now and i'm gonna find out your hiding spot no
you're not no you're not oh my god just count down give me
so much anxiety wait i'm like i'm anxious give me more time
please i'm really proud of myself right now you have opened
my eyes in a way i didn't clips on my algorithm paid off
yeah like scoot over like a little bit no no i promise you
it'll really help no i'm really serious if i scoot i'm gonna
fall oh my god nimi come here look up oh yeah yeah oh i know
what to do so we don't get to see anybody else yeah yeah
yeah wait i figured it out no one will find me i don't see
anybody snuffy i swear you'll be able to find me you're all
like Oh, this is gonna be so easy.
Oh, man.
You're like, you're like, I'm gonna catch him all.
Wait, no, let me catch one.
He is what?
Oh, oh, he got lost.
Someone might have just passed Matara.
Okay, what the hell is wrong with you?
Go back to fully admit.
I no longer want to be the hunter, you guys.
No, where are you guys?
Snuffy, turn around.
Lino, come back to where I am.
See, my chat was doubting my spot.
too powerful too powerful wait what is your spot wait very
good oh no oh no i'm thinking right now you better be oh i
messed up
wait all right it's time to find me
chocolate.
I'm a little sweet treat.
Neemie.
Neemie, I met.
Oh!
Where was she?
Katie and everything.
Oh, wow.
That is good.
I have an idea.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Maybe mine was a bad idea.
Ready or not, here I come.
Oh, why are you laughing?
a really good hiding spot with a balloon oh my god Mimi's
getting so good at this game and snuffy you know my spot is
just so easy if you guys don't find me it's super simple
yeah she's glowing
player.
Ooh, I'm so excited to see where you girls were.
Good job.
She's definitely in this room.
Oh my god!
Sabres never look up.
Alright, we'll do Minecraft now.
Okay, I'm painting.
I'm painting.
We're all locked in.
Oh my god, I forgot about this.
I forgot about painting my booty.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Sorry, what the fuck are you?
Are you SpongeBob?
I'm a SpongeBob.
Everybody have this paint on you.
What?
What the fuck?
This is your spot.
I know.
We all technically had the same idea but like executed
differently.
Oh no.
This is so difficult.
I can give you guys a hint that applies to all of us.
No!
You're okay.
Sabotage yourself.
Well, if I give my hint, it's gonna apply to all of you guys
because we all have the same idea.
If you find one of us, you might find the rest of us.
All of us.
Yeah.
Some of us are like right by Doki and we have no idea.
Yeah, you've run by Doki like a movie.
Oh!
Oh my God.
We can all do the same exact.
Yeah, we did.
We have all hidden in intersections now.
All right, let's do a speed run.
And run stuffy.
Pop, pop, pop.
Okay, yeah.
We're ready.
Yeah, this is ready for a speed run.
What a cute knit.
It's a fake person.
Wait, that's a fake.
Oh, I thought that was a real one.
I was like, who's that over there?
How small do you think they are?
It can't be that small.
Oh, fuck.
Oh my god, I can't see you.
My god, that's a fake person too.
That you poop is, yeah.
Unless there's a secret.
Because you're in the middle.
Yeah, that's fake.
I think we're all in the bathroom.
There was the only place in the house.
What about the person at the sink?
What about the person at the sink, guys?
I don't think this one needed two hunters.
This is what you guys were.
Yeah, there was like nothing to hide in or against.
I did all this guy fury for nothing.
Is it two hunters?
Because we could be SpongeBob and Patrick.
Oh, that's true.
Oh, yeah.
That's so cute.
I'm gonna be, I'll be SpongeBob.
Shorts are, are they black or blue?
Oh, they are the shorts.
They're brown, they're brown.
I just look like I shit myself.
Okay, done it.
Wait, I have an idea.
Oh, my fellow hiders, you're not even trying.
What is this?
What is that?
Yeah, where are you hiding, huh?
What the fuck?
Snuffy's spot looks like she's, like, under arrest.
It's not.
She's not even a shot.
I didn't know what to do.
Why is SpongeBob mad?
SpongeBob, don't they do a clown?
Look up, guys.
Turn around.
Oh, my God.
It was so close.
I was looking.
Oh, wait.
I'm very ambitious right now.
This might work.
This might not work.
We'll see how it goes.
Oh, Doki's ears is good.
Yours is, oh, well, kind of.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, Snuffy, yours is.
Oh, that was good, Snuffy.
It was good.
It was really good.
Oh.
No.
Limeo, I think you might be good.
Every time Min says that, we can try.
believe her lies oh wait i told you every time you say that
you get somebody killed i was trying to compliment you guys
sorry i think mince hiding place is really good too guys i
think i'm sorry but mint is just she's a ghost she's
actually just she's just watching you from beyond the grave
oh matari oh no wait i shouldn't say that should i yeah What
the hell is wrong with you guys?
It's me!
We're actually playing these walls right now.
Oh my gosh, Mint!
What are you doing?
They're never gonna find you!
I got stuck here!
Alright, so Mint is stuck somewhere.
That's the only hint, and she's near a painting, so that's
all we need to know.
Don't fall off the world, Toki bird.
Oh, thank you, bye.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
What?
Where was she?
Where is she?
I fell inside the little thingies trying to get to the
painting.
Oh my god, wait, that's crazy.
I know what I want to do.
Sometimes hiding in plain sight is the best thing to do.
Agreed, agreed.
We're snapping.
Woohoo!
Whoa!
So y'all started looking up.
My strats stopped working.
Because alien tactics are old, you guys.
Yeah, they are.
Yeah, you gotta get with the times.
No, my God, the meta changed.
Snuffy, how funny are you?
It's hilarious.
I will say, it's pretty funny.
Did Snuffy, do you see?
Oh, no, no, I'm here.
No, no, I'm here.
Man for my funniest.
Yeah, yeah.
The developer's like, take my game seriously.
Oh my God.
Wait, no, that was really good.
It's literally a mess.
This one?
Oh my God.
All right, last one.
thought i heard the little hole like this way oh oh no way i
didn't see run run run run do the part i couldn't get out of
the wall i couldn't get out of the wall wait wait wait it's
right here left she gave the horse an extra leg i would have
never seen that in that way yeah yeah ggs everyone for
organizing thank you for organizing that was fun i can't
believe leave stealing metal died out i thought i was so
smart i'll see you guys next time everybody bye